Well,
thank you everyone for attending and coming to this special session where
we're
trying to bring translational research from the San Antonio
Breast Cancer Symposium
to the AACR annual meeting. And as
you also might imagine, we have a reciprocal meeting at
the San Antonio meeting where we bring speakers from the
AACR. And so our great hope here is to cross-pollinate
the two meetings and
bring some
translational cutting-edge clinical trial research from
San Antonio to the AACR, and
then to encourage people who might do some more
basic research
to attend the San Antonio Breast Cancer
Symposium.
And so this year, from the
set of fantastic talks that we had at San Antonio,
we're bringing-- And this was somewhat unintentional, but maybe not.
We have three breast medical oncologists here,
who are physician scientists, who will be presenting their work on
three very different topics. But nonetheless,
sort of in the finest transitions of translational research, there's
often model systems, human tissues, clinical
trials, and the back and forth in between all of
those.
I do understand we're seeing an increasing amount of that here at the AACR
meeting. But again, we really want to
facilitate more of this multidisciplinary research, and that's one of the
efforts of this particular
meeting that we're at right now.
So I should say,
this has been done by myself and Carlos Arteaga, and
unfortunately, Carlos couldn't be here today.
But he gives his regards and
he was instrumental in helping to select the speakers and to keep this
sort of reciprocal meeting going.
So without further ado, allow me to
introduce the first of our speakers,
Sherene Loi from the Peter Mac Institute in Melbourne, Australia.
I will say this is the Peter Mac mini symposium,
except for Nolan. Again, unintentional.
I think I noticed that a few days ago.
But nonetheless, shows the outstanding research being done
overseas. So Sherene is a professor,
and again, breast medical oncologist specializing in breast
treatment and also expertise in genomics, immunology,
and drug development. She also co-chairs the International Breast Cancer
Study Group.
And
I don't know how people run labs and see patients and
run trials at the same time. So without further ado, Sherene will
present on parity and breastfeeding, some exciting recent
research.
Thank you, Dr Ferre, for the very generous introduction, and good morning,
everyone. And I'd like to thank San Antonio Breast Cancer
Conference for the invitation, as well as AACR. It's great to be in San Diego.
So I'm going to be talking about some of our recent research to try and understand
how reproductive events change immune responses
with regards to breast cancer.
These are my disclosures, none of which are relevant today.
Okay, so as background, breast cancer has not traditionally been considered
immunogenic, but now we have large bodies of evidence which highlight the role of
immunity and specifically T cells,
and an active role in breast cancer growth and progression.
The proof of the pudding, of course, is now that we use pembrolizumab, a T
cell checkpoint inhibitor, with chemotherapy in patients with
both early and late triple-negative breast cancer due
to significant improvements in overall survival, as shown on the
right there. But we still have limited understanding of the women who
derive the most benefit from these T cell or T cell checkpoint
targeting therapies.
So one way we've been trying to stratify patients into groups that
respond better to these type of treatments is by using the
immune infiltration in breast cancer.
Using this method we developed now well over 10 years ago, quantifying immune
infiltration in H&E stained slides.
We and others have shown that the quantity of immune infiltrations is really
important in outcomes of these patients, and specifically for
triple-negative breast cancer patients.
And they have a strong role with regards to prognosis
in the setting of no therapy, chemotherapy, and now in the
context of neoadjuvant chemotherapy and immunotherapy.
They also have a role in prediction of response in advanced disease as
well. But we still, again, have very limited understanding of
the women, why they have high and low levels of immune infiltrate, and also the
molecular characteristics of the high infiltration, which is
associated with better responses to these treatments.
So we started studying the heterogeneity in the T cell infiltrates,
specifically in patients that had higher levels of this immune infiltration
because they did better to try and ask the question, what are the molecular
characteristics of this immune infiltrate?
We did this using single cell sequencing, and as well as
observing a very distinct large amount of molecular
heterogeneity. We were very interested in one subset of T cells,
expressed high levels of checkpoints such as PD-1,
TIM-3, for example, which was important back then because we were still developing
these therapies in breast cancer.
It also had markers of perforin and granzyme, which
suggested they were cytotoxic and mediated tumor killing.
But importantly, they also had markers that were characteristic of what we
understand were features of residency, and these
include-Decreased expression of these markers down here,
but also increased expression of this integrin here, ITGAE or
CD103. And CD103 is important because it forms a
heterodimer and binds onto ecaderin, which is a molecule which
is widely expressed on breast cancer epithelial cells.
So this suggested to us that this T cell subset was localized
to the breast epithelium and could help mediate a better anti-tumor
response.
So what do we know about TRMs or tissue resident memory T cells?
So back then, they were well-characterized in the literature, infection literature
mainly. These are memory T cells, so we have circulating memory T cells.
But when we're exposed to a pathogen, for example, virus, flu, or
COVID, we generate memory T cells, and some of these memory
T cells stay in the organ that was initially exposed
to that infection. So these T cells acquire what we call markers of
residency. They stay located in, for example, in that
example with a lung. And next time you re-expose this
pathogen, they provide an immediate and
very robust defense against that pathogen.
Such is the case that you may not actually have any symptoms of being reinfected
with that pathogen again.
So these T cells are robust. They form immediate defense.
They also remain in the tissue despite having no antigen
there. And they also have high markers of checkpoints, which suggests that
these are not exhausted T cells, but potentially could be targeted by similar
therapies. So in the cancer setting, we
thought that they could be important.
And as supportive of this Kaplan-Meier curve, when we looked at a
signature that was just taken from these TRM
cells and compared it to just a generic CD8 gene expression,
we found that the TRM signature provided
better prognostication, suggesting that this
representation of a localized immune response also represented a
systemic anti-tumor immune response that could protect against distant
recurrence.
We then went on to model this in a mouse to try and understand if they could
respond to checkpoint blockade. And we found that in this mouse tumor
model that they could. And interestingly, what we found in the mice that were
treated with checkpoint blockade, that there were 60% of the mice that cleared
their tumors from their mammary fat pad.
And we found that these TRM-like cells remain in the mammary fat pad that
was free of tumor.
So then we asked the question: Could these T cells provide protection against
tumor rechallenge? And so we did this in the setting of an agent called
FTY720. And what this does is inhibits the T
cells from the lymph nodes, so we can just see the effect of the T cells
within the localized area.
So we did the experiment for these mice. We rechallenged the mice with tumor.
And what we found in the local mammary fat pad that was originally exposed to the
tumor, we found that this mammary fat pad was protected from tumor
rechallenge in the setting of FTY, which suggested that these
local T cells could proliferate, expand, and provide anti-tumor
protection, as you can see here. But interestingly, in
the contralateral mammary fat pad that had never been exposed to tumor
cells, we also saw protection there as well, suggesting that we
had a localized memory response, but also a systemic
anti-tumor response that could protect against distant recurrence.
And the fact that these TRM cells were present in the normal mammary
fat pad without any tumor suggested that these were very similar to
the TRM cells we saw in infection.
But that, of course, led us to the question,
if
these TRM cells could remain in the normal mammary fat pad without tumor, does this
happen also in humans? So next, we looked at human normal
breasts. So this was cancer-unaffected normal breast.
And we found that indeed,
not in the same quantities as in primary tumors, in this case,
triple-negative breast cancer, but in normal breast that was cancer unaffected, as
you can see there, there's a significant number of T cells present in
the breast tissue. And these T cells express this
resident memory phenotype that we were interested in.
So that begs the question, these are normal breast.
This is a normal, healthy breast. Why are there T cells in a normal, healthy
breast? And do they have a part to play in immune surveillance and breast
cancer protection?
So this, of course, led us to try and look at the role of
pregnancy and breastfeeding. So we know that breast cancer is rising
globally in the world, specifically in younger women.
A lot of this risk is thought to be related to changing in reproductive
lifestyles and also
decreasing age of menarche. The risk is highest in women that
are non-childbearing and lowest in women who have children and breastfed, and this
has been observed for many centuries, actually.
The mechanisms have largely been thought to be related to hormones and changes in
the breast structure, post-pregnancy and breastfeeding. And this risk is nuanced.
Your risk of breast cancer does rise immediately postpartum, but ultimately becomes
protective the longer from your last child.
And you can see here in this
meta-analysis from "The Lancet," for every child, your risk of breast cancer is
reduced by 7% and a further reduction for every 12
months of breastfeeding.
But as we've understood about breast cancer subtypes, what we've realized is that
this breastfeeding effect seems very specific to triple-negative
breast cancer. So you can see here, the longer duration you've breastfed, the
lower your risk of triple-negative breast cancer, and this doesn't seem to be the
case for the hormone-responsive tumors, where age at first birth seems to
be most important. So this got us thinking, triple-negative breast cancer,
high amounts of T cell infiltrate. We use pembrolizumab.
Is this
what we're observing here related to T cells?
So then we ask the questionAt the start, DOOP
women who'd had children had more T cells in their normal cancer unaffected
breast. So we did this in two ways. We looked at women of average risk
who'd had breast reductions, and we also looked at women of high risk who'd had
prophylactic mastectomies. So up here, we looked at single cell RNA
seq data from women who had breast reductions, and as you can see here in
orange, in the Paris women, there are high numbers of immune
cells, high number of T cells, CD8 T cells,
and specifically our TRM phenotype of interest.
And similarly, in women who are high risk, who'd had prophylactic mastectomies, so
usually germline carriers, again, we see a significantly high levels of immune
cells, CD3 positive T cells, and again, this
TRM phenotype of interest in this normal
cancer unaffected breast.
Using OPAL, you can see that these little dots representing the TRM cells, and
this is the Paris normal breast and the nulliparous breast, and you can see many
more of these dots in the Paris breast, and they're closer to the ductal
epithelium, suggesting they have a role in immune surveillance.
And just of note that these cells are very long-lived.
We had some samples that were 30 years from their last child, and these T
cells were still present, suggesting that these T cells can exist in the
breast for a very long period of time.
So next question we asked was, so we've made this observation in women,
can we model this in a mouse? So the first thing we asked was, can we see
similar findings in a mouse model?
So we used a model of a mouse that
had pups and that had undergone full lactation and
involution. So in a mouse, lactation is around 21 days,
this is just the average period. Then
the pups are removed, and the mammary fat pad undergoes
involution, and by day 28 post-involution, the mammary fat pad has
returned to looking histologically like the pre-pregnancy state.
So we compared the immune cell components of these two conditions, and
what we found was really the only main immune cell that was increased in
the day 28 model were the mammary T cells, and
as you can see here. And these T cells, there was a higher level of T cells,
higher amount of T cells that express this TRM phenotype.
As a control, we also looked at a model of an earlier
postpartum time point, and this time point has been quite well characterized in
the literature because it's associated with poorer outcomes.
This is thought to be related to the macrophage content at this time,
this forced involution time point.
And indeed, we did see a high level of macrophages at this time point,
and only very slightly higher levels of CD8 and nowhere near the magnitude that we
saw in the day 208.
Visually, again, you can see this in the OPAL images.
You can see here in this day 28 model here, the mammary fat pad, all the
little dots representing a significantly high amount of TRM-like cells compared
to the virgin mouse.
So then the next question we asked was, now we've seen this increase in the immune
content of T cells, is it functional? Can it restrain tumor growth?
So we implanted tumor cells at these same time points.
And what we found was in the day 10 time point, the forced wean time point, where
we saw the macrophage infiltrate, we saw no difference in
the tumors that grew when implanted at these time points compared to virgin.
In contrast, however, at the day 28 time point, so the mice that had undergone
full lactation and involution, we saw significantly smaller tumors
at this endpoint, as you can see there.
So this T cell difference does seem to have a functional impact on tumor
growth.
What is the till content within these tumors?
As we know in humans, higher amounts of immune infiltrate has
prognostic
implications. And you can see at this day 28 time point here that
these tumors have higher levels of CD8 positive T cells.
There's more over positive, so more antigen positive T cells.
These T cells express PD-1, and there's higher amounts of
this type one DC. So these subsets of course, are
very important in mediating response to pembrolizumab or T cell
checkpoint therapies. So not only are the
tumors smaller at this time point, they had more T cell content.
And then finally, we asked the question, is this protection or smaller
tumors that we're seeing specifically related to CD8 positive T
cells? So to try and help us to understand this specific
mechanism, we use RAG mice. So RAG mice lack
NK, T, and B cells. We use the same time points.
And what we found was that we lost protection in the day 28
mouse. See here, the tumors are exactly the same size.
So this implies that this benefit we see in the Paris mouse is
immune cell dependent.
The next thing we did was in this RAG mouse, we injected CD8 positive T
cells that recognize OVA. And we did this at the day
28, day 10 time points. And what we found that in the day
28 time point, that this protection was restored.
And you can see there, this is quite impressive tumor reduction at this
particular time point
associated with an increased number of these TRM-like cells at
this time point as well. In contrast, at the earlier time point, the day 10,
we see no difference in tumor size.
So this tells us that adoptive CD8 positive T cells
into RAG mice can return the protection that we
saw originally in the
immune competent mouse.
And then the next thing we did was CD8 depletions.
We did both alpha and beta depletions.
And as you can see here that the four and eight depletion,
we lose protection. So this phenocopies the virgin mouse, and we lose
protection with both alpha and beta depletions, suggesting that this protection
is reliant on conventional CD8 positive T cells and
not innate-like T cells.And then finally, we
looked at the effect using this molecule
FTY720. So as you might recall, this really allows us
to dissect the contribution of the local versus the circulating memory T
cells. And what we found was, unlike the tumor model
previously, we found that we lose protection in the parous
mouse, as you can see there, compared to control.
So this suggests that not only are the local T cells important, but
it recruits circulating memory T cells.
And it does suggest that actually not only does the local immunity change, but
the systemic immune system also changes in the parous
mouse.
So, the next thing we asked was about breastfeeding.
It's very hard to deconvolute breastfeeding in the mouse model, so we went back to
patients, and we asked, is it associated with
further breast cancer protection
over parity alone?
For this, we look far and wide actually for datasets that had collected
information on parity and breastfeeding.
This is actually quite hard to find, so I ask you all to collect this now more
systematically in your patients.
But this Malaysian dataset had collected parity and breastfeeding history
in women who developed breast cancer after their last child.
And what we found was in the triple-negative breast cancer patients,
their tumors, if they had
children and had longer duration breastfeeding, they had higher levels of
immune infiltration compared to nulliparous women, this in quite
specific to triple-negative breast cancer.
And using spatial OPA, we found that this T cell
content was more intratumoral in the patients in the women who had
breastfed.
Next, we looked at women of high risk, so BRCA carriers who developed also
breast cancer after their last child.
And you can see here that not only was the duration of breastfeeding associated
with higher levels of TIL infiltrating the tumors, but this seemed to mediate
improved survival in this cohort of high-risk women.
So breastfeeding was associated with improved survival as well as higher TIL
infiltrate, suggesting that longer breastfeeding duration adds
further immune protection for these women.
So in summary, our findings show that parity and
breastfeeding and involution reshape the normal and breast immune
landscape. This immune remodeling results in accumulation of CD8
T cells within the breast. It's probably evolved as
to protect the mother against infection.
But in the cancer context, this results in enhanced immune
surveillance, better recruitment of circulating T cells in case of tumor
development, smaller tumors, and more tumoral immune
infiltration. So we conclude that reproductive history is important in shaping
the immune biology of the breast and the mother
for protection against specifically triple-negative breast cancer.
So in conclusion, immunotherapy is now standard of care for patients with
triple-negative breast cancer. Tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes or
TIL in the tumor reflect more than just tumor mutational burden.
The immune microenvironment is shaped not only by neoantigens but by host
physiology.
Parity, breastfeeding, and involution remodel the normal breast and
systemic immunity of the mother to provide durable CD8-mediated
T cell protection against triple-negative breast cancer.
And we believe these data provide a mechanism for the long-standing
epidemiological observation of this association.
Reproductive history, specifically duration of breastfeeding, should be collected
in all future breast cancer immuno-oncology trials.
And our data suggests that women will have variable responses to
immunotherapy depending on their parity and breastfeeding history.
Translating parity-driven pathways could yield therapeutic strategies for both
prevention and treatment. So hopefully, women,
if they don't choose to have children or breastfeed, we can mimic and provide
therapeutic interventions that are similar.
And finally, our data highlights the importance of normal breast
tissue immune health, and this is actually a modifier or
determinant of tumor control.
So with that, I'd like to thank you for your attention.
I'd like to specifically highlight the four postdocs that worked on this
project. My collaborator, Laura McKay at Peter Mac,
specifically, and other collaborators, Paul Neeson and Phil Darcy from Peter
Mac, and also Jee Win Pan from the Malaysian Cancer Institute,
and of course, my funding bodies, and thank you for your attention.
So we have time and encourage questions from the audience.
If you have a question, please come up to one of the two microphones here.
Please go ahead.
Hi. I'm Carol from the Salk Institute. Beautiful work.
I have a couple questions. I don't know if there's any studies, but do you think
having mastitis or any infection during breastfeeding could even
increase these T cells or have any effect?
It's highly plausible that this all contributes to the
localized T cell recruitment and infiltration, yes.
So you think, for example, in mice that are pathogen-free, we wouldn't see that big
increase of T cells or it's just the
remodeling of the epithelial in the mammary gland?
They're all excellent questions.
We probably think it's a combination, but we do believe the remodeling of the
mammary gland post lactation and pregnancy lactation
involution does contribute to the recruitment of T cells,
yes.
Okay. And last question. More pregnancies makes you
higher number of T cells?
So our data suggests longer duration breastfeeding in total
cumulative over.
Okay.
But of course, you can't breastfeed without pregnancy, right?
Right.
So it's quite hard to deconvolute.
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sharyn, for that great presentation.
I was thinking that maybe lactation looks like a vaccination.
So I was thinking if you would target a population with
that potential vaccine, would you target the whole
population or just triple-negative?
Yes. So one potential translation is that if we
could find the antigen, of course, that is a hard thing to do, you could
potentially think of vaccine strategies similar, analogous to HPV
vaccine, for example. But I think it might be a bit more complicated than that,
because obviously if it's antigen-related, this antigen has to be expressed across
all HLA types.
And if it's a self-antigen,
then you don't want to cause autoimmunity.
So I think it's more complicated than antigen.
There must be other signals around the antigen presentation that result
in the whole immune response. I think it's possible, plausible, but
there's a lot more work to do.
Any ideas on the antigen?
We have ideas, but nothing proven as yet.
Thank you.
Hi. You mentioned the circulating T cells were also
important-
Yes
... as far as this. I was curious, is it possible to do a blood biopsy to determine
if they have those so that you can better judge the progression of the
tumor?
So I guess we're studying at the moment, breast milk, for example,
and seeing if the T cell repertoire in breast milk can be reflected in the blood of
the mother, and if that changes. So I guess it's possible, yes.
Okay. Thank you.
Last question.
Hi. Great talk. I was just wondering if this immune phenotype that you
see, if you think that it's potentially related to
prolactin. And I guess
it would be maybe a small population, but women that had not had children but
had maybe prolactinomas or something that could help you determine
if
it's related to that.
Yeah. It's a great question. We think prolactin has a role, but I
think we also can't discount the whole remodeling of the tissue, yes-
Right
... as well as the hormonal effects.
So, I think it's very complicated, and obviously this evolved-
Yeah
... over to keep mothers alive. So I think it's probably going to be quite
complicated. Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
But great question.
So Shareena, I'll ask a question. You don't get to leave yet.
So I'll start by saying, on the Carolina Breast
Cancer Study, we have parity and
breastfeeding information. So that might be
another study we could collaborate on
and confirm, I think, many of your findings.
And I also wonder, so why TNBC
and not the other types that really show this breastfeeding
effect?
Yeah. We haven't looked a lot at the other, but it's possible, I
think, that the other highly proliferative subtypes will have mediate similar
effects as well. And just to highlight that it's not only duration of breastfeeding
that's important, but time from last child also is important as well,
because the breast obviously has to go back to a pre-involution state.
And in the human, unlike the mouse, it takes some time.
All right. Thank you. That was awesome.
Oh. All right. So our next speaker,
also from the Peter Mac, is an associate professor,
another clinician scientist.
And
Shyam serves as a PI on a number of global
trials,
and has done a lot of
outstanding research on the tumor suppressors, particularly the Rb
pathway, and that's what we'll be hearing about today.
Thank you for the introduction. Good morning, everyone.
First I'd like to thank Dr. Perou and also Dr.
Arteaga for the invitation to present here.
And I'm going to talk to you today about some unpublished work from my lab looking
at novel functions of the retinoblastoma tumor suppressor
protein, or as we call it, Rb.
So here are my disclosures.
Before I begin, I just wanted to acknowledge the two postdocs in my lab who really
led this work, April Watt and Antonio Arn.
And I'd also like to acknowledge the rest of our team, and importantly,
the various funding bodies that have supported the work I'm going to present to you
today.
So just to briefly reorient you to Rb, I think as you all know,
Rb is a canonical tumor suppressor protein.
In fact, it was the first tumor suppressor to ever be discovered.
And in that role, Rb essentially enforces
cell cycle arrest in the G1 phase of the cell cycle.
Basically, when Rb is active, it represses the E2F
transcription factors, and it prevents the expression of
genes that are required for entry into S phase.
And it's become very interesting to study Rb again recently
because now we have drugs that can
selectively and directly activate this
repressive function of Rb. Of course, I'm talking about the CDK4/6
inhibitors. These drugs work by preventing the phosphorylation of
Rb, driving it to the chromatin where it binds to and
represses the E2F factors and induces G1
cell cycle arrest. And we know that this principle is exactly what
happens in patients because we have a series of
older studies where these drugs were used as monotherapy, and
it was shown in hormone receptor-positive tumors that CDK4/6
inhibitors do indeed reduce the phosphorylation of Rb.
They do reduce indices of tumor cell proliferation, and
they do repress the expression of E2F target genes in
tumors.
But there's a bit of a disconnect, I think, because as monotherapy,
despite those findings, we know that these drugs in the clinic have fairly
modest activity. And the real clinical impact and benefit
that we've seen has always come when they've been combined with endocrine
therapy. And it kind of raises a pretty simple question, I guess, which
is, if activating Rb with these drugs is so good at
suppressing proliferation, why isn't that enough on its
own?So that's not the exact question that
we posed when we started this work,
but it will become relevant in my talk.
We actually started by asking a broader, more unbiased question.
What we really asked is, when we activate Rb with a CDK4/6
inhibitor, well, we know it's going to E2F transcription factors
at cell cycle gene promoters and repressing those genes,
but what else is Rb doing on the chromatin?
There is some older literature, 20, 30 years old, suggesting that
Rb might be able to bind other transcription factors or other chromatin
modifiers to influence other gene expression programs, but
this all comes from the pre-genomic era.
And what Rb is doing on the chromatin in cancer
cells once it's been drug activated has essentially
never been explored before.
And so despite how critical Rb is
in this disease, we actually have no clear picture of what it does on the
chromatin in these cancer cells, except for repressing the cell cycle.
I think one of the main reasons we don't know this is because to study this
question, one would need to map Rb on the chromatin genome-wide using
techniques such as ChIP-seq. And that has just
been notoriously very difficult from a technical standpoint for those of
us who work in this field. And so it remains this black
box actually in the field, not knowing what the transcriptional consequences and
hence what the clinical consequences are of activating Rb
in breast cancers.
So to look at this, our lab really set out with the primary goal of trying
to find a good way to map Rb's genome-wide
distribution on the chromatin. And we turned to this more
modern epigenetic profiling method, CUT&RUN.
And with CUT&RUN, we've been able to generate some robust
genome-wide maps of Rb chromatin occupancy in breast cancer cells.
We first proved that this is indeed a specific Rb CUT&RUN
signal because when we knock out Rb, we lose all signal, and we went on to
then ask the question, how does Rb activation with CDK4/6
inhibition change its distribution on the chromatin?
So as you can imagine, when we treat with CDK4/6 inhibitors, we see a reduction in
Rb phosphorylation, we see accumulation of cells in G1,
and what we also see is a marked increase in chromatin-bound
Rb, thousands of regions gaining Rb binding,
very few regions losing Rb binding.
So activation of Rb is basically associated with a widespread
distribution of Rb across the genome.
And I guess that's consistent with the old notion that it is this
hypophosphorylated active form of Rb that is the
chromatin-associated form of Rb.
So we then asked the question, well, where are these binding events occurring?
And what we found in these two cell line models was that the majority, about
three-quarters of Rb binding events are happening over gene promoters.
And this is looking at over 10,000 different regions throughout the genome in
these cells. So it's a much broader promoter landscape than just the
classical cell cycle genes that we typically think about.
And importantly, a substantial fraction is also happening at non-promoter
regions. Thousands of non-promoter regions are also gaining Rb binding, and this
is, to us, very interesting because Rb function at these
non-promoter regions has essentially never been explored.
And we confirmed these findings by developing assays to map Rb in
vivo. So this is a PDX model of hormone receptor-positive breast cancer,
and again, we see very similar redistribution of Rb over the
chromatin with treatment. And to our knowledge, this on the right is the first
time that Rb distribution on chromatin has ever been mapped
in any tissue context whatsoever.
So then we asked, okay, let's start with the promoter binding events first and see
if they do in fact show the Rb biology that we expect.
And so when we look at the promoters that gain Rb binding after CDK4/6
inhibitor treatment, we found strong enrichment for E2F motifs,
consistent with the role of Rb, I guess, in
repressing E2F-mediated transcription.
Ontologically, those genes were heavily enriched for cell cycle processes and
of course, the E2F target genes were heavily repressed by treatment.
So at least this confirms our approach is capturing the canonical
functions of Rb at cell cycle gene promoters, but it also tells us that
there's a much broader chromatin landscape that Rb is occupying that
we don't yet understand.
So just to illustrate that more concretely here, here's just some examples of
Rb accumulating at the promoters of cell cycle genes
after treatment. And you can also see at those same promoters that there's
reduced H3K27 acetylation, which is reduced transcriptional
activity, and that's consistent with Rb's known role to
recruit histone deacetylases to cell cycle
promoters to repress gene expression.
But we then were really interested in what's going on at these non-promoter sites
that are gaining Rb binding after CDK4/6 inhibitor treatment, because unlike
the promoter sites that we've looked at, these regions show, interestingly, a very
different pattern.
What we found here was that these
non-promoter sites where Rb bound were marked by
H3K27 acetylation, and in fact, the level of
H3K27 acetylation increased
with treatment.
And also when we integrated with RNA-seq, we found that the
genes that were located near these regions were more likely to be
upregulated
rather than suppressed. So instead of behaving like classic repressive
sites, these regions seem to have the features of active enhancers,
and their activity seems to increase with Rb
recruitment.
Importantly, these non-promoter Rb binding sites were highly consistent across
models. So we saw the exact same regions gaining Rb binding in both
cell line models and in the PDX model, as shown here, which suggests
this is a very reproducible feature of Rb
activation.And so we next asked the question: well, what are the
genes associated with these sites?
And I guess somewhat unexpectedly, across all the data sets
that we looked at in all conditions, in vitro and in vivo, with two different
CDK4/6 inhibitors,
we found that the non-promoter sites gaining Rb binding were heavily
enriched for proximity to estrogen response genes.
And even when we restricted the analysis to those sites which gained Rb
binding and where the nearby gene was significantly upregulated, again, the
top hit was estrogen response.
So here's some examples. There's some classic estrogen receptor target
genes, and you can see increased Rb binding at non-promoter
regions located within the gene or near the gene.
And although I told you we found this estrogen response signal by looking at the
non-promoter sites binding Rb, we also often
saw some increase in Rb binding at the promoters of these genes
as well. Now, these are not classical ER target genes,
but it's suggesting that Rb is, in addition to ER target genes, being
recruited to both enhancer and promoter regions around this set of
estrogen response genes as well.
So having seen Rb being recruited to these regions
around ER target genes, and having seen that increase in
H3K27 acetylation at the non-promoter regions where Rb was
bound,
we asked the question: are these ER target genes being upregulated by
treatment? And so we looked at this in multiple systems, first of all, in three
different cell lines, just using RNA sequencing,
in PDX models,
and also in a unique clinical cohort of patients
treated with CDK4/6 inhibitor monotherapy, where we had paired
biopsies before
and after treatment. And in each of these three systems,
expression profiling showed that the top upregulated gene set
was the estrogen response. And the clinical data is, I think, particularly powerful
here because getting paired biopsies before and after the
CDK4/6 inhibitor monotherapy is a very difficult thing to do.
And here we have these matched paired samples, not only from
treated patients, from also from a group of patients who had no treatment, which
means that the data we're generating is really quite robust in showing us
treatment-specific effects.
So at this point, we have clear evidence that Rb is being recruited around
these ER target genes, and we show that these genes are being upregulated.
But we really wanted to understand whether or not Rb recruitment to these
regions is directly responsible for the upregulation of
those genes.
So first we just knocked out Rb globally, and we found that the
induction of the estrogen response
is no longer seen. And that's encouraging, but this is difficult to
interpret because in these sorts of cells, when you knock out Rb, you
disrupt multiple aspects of CDK4/6 inhibitor response.
The cells even start cycling in response to drug.
And so it's hard to interpret whether what we're showing is relating to a direct
chromatin resident function of Rb.
So to try and answer this more concretely,
we took a more targeted approach, and we used a method called
H3K27 acetylation HiChIP, and this allows us to
map physical interactions between promoters and
enhancers that are marked by active chromatin.
And so we can basically link those distal regulatory elements to the very
genes that they're controlling. And using this, we could identify
some specific enhancers which were new loops
that newly formed upon treatment, and which showed increased
Rb binding at the time of treatment and looped to the promoters
of estrogen response target genes.
And using CRISPR-Cas9, we selectively disrupted
those individual enhancers. So we're not perturbing Rb globally,
we're not perturbing its effects on the cell cycle, but specifically looking at its
function at those loci. And what we found was that disruption of
Rb
at those enhancers or Rb binding had no impact on gene
expression in the basal conditions, but it did
impair the upregulation of these estrogen response target
genes in the face of treatment. And this was even evident at the
protein level here. So looking at the classic gene cyclin D, for example, where the
upregulation of cyclin D is significantly less if these
Rb-bound enhancers are treated with CRISPR.
And so this collectively, I think this data now really do support this model in
which Rb binding at enhancers is playing a direct functional
role in driving this estrogen response program.
So having seen that,
and having seen that these drugs are inducing this ER transcriptional program,
I guess we started to wonder what this could mean for patients.
Because in particular, we wondered whether this could explain what we see all the
time, which is, as I said before, CDK4/6 inhibitors have
modest impact when given as monotherapy, but very
powerful efficacy when given together with endocrine therapy, which would
block this estrogen response.
And we've known for many years that higher levels of ER target gene
expression in general are linked to better endocrine
sensitivity, and so it raises the possibility, I guess,
that by inducing this ER target gene program,
CDK4/6 inhibitors are basically making cells more endocrine
sensitive. And we saw similar things in our own systems.
For example, we found that when we treat cells with a combination of CDK4/6
inhibitors and endocrine therapy, we get much deeper
suppression of cell cycle genes compared to just using a CDK4/6
inhibitor alone. And this is associated with deeper
suppression of S-phase entry
and also prevention of cell outgrowth in long-term in vitro
assays. So it basically raises the possibility that this
Rb-driven
estrogen response program that we're seeing may be linked to the
therapeutic synergy that we're all familiar
with.So we then began to ask, well,
which part of this ER program
might be working to actually limit the full extent of cell
cycle arrest? And we focused on cyclin D1, which I've talked to you about already.
And we focused on cyclin D1 for a few different reasons.
First of all, it's a well-known ER target gene.
We've shown, and others have shown, that it's upregulated by CDK4/6 inhibitors,
that this is dependent on ER, and it's also dependent, this
upregulation, on Rb. And
importantly, as I showed you earlier, we showed that when we disrupted the Rb-bound
enhancers around cyclin D, it prevented the upregulation of cyclin D
protein. So, this gave us a specific candidate to
focus on
within this broader estrogen response program that could be clinically relevant.
So we asked the question, well, what happens if we remove this specific signal?
Rather than blocking ER, if we just take away cyclin D1.
So the first thing we found is that if you knock down cyclin D1, in addition to
giving a CDK4/6 inhibitor, it leads to a much deeper
suppression of cell cycle genes compared to CDK4/6
inhibitors alone,
suggesting that this induction of cyclin D that we're getting may be acting to
partially counteract the effects of Rb
activation. And so basically that's led us to this model,
which says that when we treat our breast cancer cells with CDK4/6 inhibitors,
yes, active Rb is going to E2F factors and repressing
target genes, but at the same time, it is being
recruited to other enhancers and promoters at ER target genes
where it's driving their expression, and that program includes
pro-proliferative genes such as cyclin D.
And in this setting, really the fascinating thing to me is that Rb is doing two
things at once. On the one hand, it's enforcing cell cycle arrest.
But at the same time, it is activating a program that can push back
against that arrest.
Now, if you happen to have good endocrine therapy, which fortunately we often do,
you can neutralize that second component and get deep
cell cycle suppression and potent therapeutic synergy.
And this is probably a new and quite simple way of thinking about the synergy that
we see in the clinic all the time.
What we've also done a lot of work on, I don't have time to show the actual data
here, is thinking about what this might mean in the setting of
endocrine-resistant disease, for example, tumors with ESR1 mutations.
Because at a high level, what we've seen here is that
CDK4/6 inhibitors can also activate this estrogen receptor response
in ESR1 mutant tumors. But now, if you're treating the tumor with
ineffective endocrine therapy, like an aromatase inhibitor, for
example, you're not able to neutralize that response.
Cyclin D1 levels remain elevated, and it can promote
earlier outgrowth of cells in the face of treatment.
If you were to switch over to a drug that can effectively degrade the mutant
ER, like a SERD,
you can overcome this. Cyclin D1 levels go back down, and you get deeper cell
cycle suppression. And again, in this context of ESR1 mutants, we
also found that rather than switching the whole endocrine program, if you just
knock down cyclin D1, you can also again deeply suppress the E2F target
genes and restore tumor cell cycle control.
And finally, I'm not going to talk about all this data, but I'll just mention
briefly that we have also worked through the mechanism
underlying this effect. So why would Rb going to these regions lead
to the upregulation of genes?
And we've done experiments such as IP-mass spec, looking for things that
bind to Rb in the nucleus, and lots of chromatin profiling of
a variety of different suspect factors that could be implicated.
And the model that we've currently settled on can be summarized like this.
Around these ER target genes, there are regions where the estrogen receptor is
clearly bound, and in a complex with it is this histone demethylase
KDM5A. I'm sure there are other factors as well.
When we treat with a CDK4/6 inhibitor and Rb goes to the chromatin,
it joins them, and we can see all three of these proteins interacting with each
other. Now, this KDM5A is normally sitting at these
genes and causing them to be partially repressed.
When Rb comes and binds to KDM5A like this, it
actually interferes with KDM5A's function, so you
essentially relieve the repression of those ER target
genes, and that is, we think, why these genes are getting upregulated with
CDK4/6 inhibitor treatment.
So to summarize then,
as I've shown you, I think CDK4/6 inhibitors, we now see for the first time
induce a very widespread redistribution of Rb
along chromatin, not only to cell cycle gene promoters, but to
other regions, most
obviously around estrogen response target genes.
And as I said, the most fascinating component of this to me is that
we can see Rb very unexpectedly, not purely acting as a tumor
suppressor, but also being able to drive the expression of a
pro-proliferative gene in these tumors.
And I think broadly, the findings that I've shown you are consistent with what
we've sort of known about Rb for a long time, but not fully understood, which
is we've always thought of it as a protein that can both repress the cell
cycle, but sort of enforce lineage identity, and that means for these tumors,
enforce luminal identity and enforce the expression of ER target genes.
And what we're very focused now on in the lab is, okay, if
this synergy that we stumbled across in the clinic explains why
patients with ER-positive breast cancer do so well with these drugs,
maybe we need to start thinking about what the transcriptional programs are that Rb
drives in other tumor types in the hope that we could identify
therapeutic combinations that could be beneficial and bring these
CDK4/6 inhibitors into solid tumor oncology more broadly.
So with that, I'll close. I'll just say thanks very much for your attention.
And if I can just very briefly mention,
a few years ago in Australia, this is a completely tangential point, we opened a
very major funding scheme called the Snow Fellowship Program, and
we'reWe're really at a phase right now where we're very keen to attract
strong early to mid-career lab heads
who'd like to join. So if anyone's at that stage in their career and thinking
Australia might be an attractive option, please do contact me. Thank you.
All right, so questions, please come to the microphones. Charlie.
Sean, that was really remarkable work, I have to say.
It's great to see the Rb field being revived like this.
So I've got lots of questions. I guess the first one is, does Rb bind ER
directly or through KDM5A? And if so, how does it
bind up ER? And is it mutually
exclusive with E2F binding? Is it the same pocket?
That's the first question.
Yeah, it's a very good question, too.
We can say that it definitely does bind.
Well, no, actually, what we can say is that Rb, ER, and
KDM5A all exist in a complex.
Right.
So we've done three-way immunoprecipitation, and whichever one of those three
proteins you pull down, you can always identify the other two
bound to your bait protein. What we haven't been able to
demonstrate clearly yet is whether there is a direct interaction
between Rb and ER, and therefore, also what parts of those proteins would be
implicated.
Right. Okay. That's interesting.
So I'm just wondering if there are mutations that would abrogate Rb
suppression of E2F but maintain Rb's ability to drive cyclin D.
Yeah. So we are definitely looking at this now.
Yeah.
As I'm sure you know,
many years ago in the field, there were Rb mutants made that sort of had the
opposite thing, where they could no longer bind E2Fs but could still do other
things. And it's been shown that by mutating or disrupting
certain parts of Rb, you can disentangle-
Yeah
... its different transcriptional-
... components. For example, there's one Rb mutant which cannot cause cell cycle
arrest but can still drive cellular enlargement, for example.
Right.
So we're looking at this now-
Yeah
... to see if we can do the same.
Super. And then if you think about non-endocrine tissues, let's say like the
retina, for example,
is there any reason to believe, in a female retina versus a
male retina, that perhaps the biology of retina blastoma
might be different between males and females because of this ER-specific
pro-proliferative cyclin D effect?
Yeah. The retina is not my expert
area, but what I can tell you is we've thought a lot about whether this ER-driven
program could apply outside of mammary tissue.
Yeah.
And in fact, we've actually looked at some
normal cell lines, which are non-mammary, like normal liver
epithelium and normal fibroblasts, and you do see
induction of the ER program in some of these tissues with these
drugs.
Yeah.
And what's fascinating to us is we've known in the breast field for a while
that when you give potent endocrine therapy, women suffer with
terrible toxicities, arthralgias, hot flushes, and so on.
When you give a CDK4/6 inhibitor together with an endocrine therapy, it's often
been reported that those toxicities are slightly less.
Mm.
And what we see in our breast cancer cell lines is that endocrine therapy causes
deep suppression of ER targets, and the combination, the suppression is slightly
less. So we've also been wondering whether
outside of the breast, this same phenomenon could be at play.
Okay. And forgive me, I've got one last question, which is the ER, the
non-E2F promoters
in your work-
Oh, yes
... is it all Rb, ER, or are there other possibilities?
Does your work explain all of those non-RbE2F interactions
with DNA? In other words, could it be Rb and PR or Rb and
another DNA-binding
transcription factor that's contributing to
this sort of non-E2F promoter activity you
see?
Look, to be honest,
we've
focused on the estrogen response because, as I showed you, when we looked at peak
binding and ontology analyses, it's the top hit, and it's obviously very relevant
to this disease. But we're talking about, in the cell lines,
10,000-ish
promoter binding. Now, that doesn't mean 10,000 genes because several promoters
show more than one peak, but it does mean 6,000, 7,000 genes are showing Rb
binding after treatment. And some of those
genes are being upregulated, some are down,
some are not changing. And it's amazing to me that
because we've never mapped Rb on chromatin before and never realized
that this is happening,
we have zero understanding of what Rb is doing at these sites.
And
we have to be careful calling them non-E2F because actually some of those
promoters,
even the non-cell cycle gene promoters,
have E2F bound. So E2F can still be
potentially acting as an Rb recruiter at genes which are
not cell cycle-related, and
if that's repressive or not, nobody knows.
Okay.
Yeah.
Jeff.
So that was a really interesting talk.
Thank you.
Very provocative. I forgot who said it.
Somebody once said, "Not all models are wrong, but the
best ones are useful."
Yours is very useful because it makes-
Thank you
... some very obvious predictions.
There are two predictions. The first one is that under these
conditions of palbociclib
administration, KDM5A activity
should be reduced. Have you looked at that?
So we've not done direct biochemical measurements
of its demethylase activity.
So the main substrate, as you know, is H3K4 trimethyl.
So we have done profiling of H3K4 trimethyl,
specifically focusing on the genes where we see Rb,
ER, and KDM5A all co-bound at one region.
And, yeah, I didn't show it today, but we see
broadening-Of the H3K4 trimethyl peaks
To suggest that there is some inactivation.
It suggests. Yeah.
The second one is that you've mentioned E2F, but of course, there are
seven of them. And so do you know whether
perhaps there's a shift in binding to the
E2Fs so that
when RB is acting as a repressor, it's binding to
E2F1 and two, but
under other conditions, it's binding to a different subset of E2Fs
induced by palbociclib itself?
Yeah. So that's also an excellent question.
And again, as I said to Charles, it's a
complete black box.
So
one of our lab members is now... It's tricky, right?
Because we then have to-
Yep
... to prove that
well, we need to profile the distribution of each E2F
factor on the chromatin pre- and post-treatment in these cells.
Sometimes you'll see multiple factors at the same position at
once and try to dissect out
RB E2F individual, E2F binding at each of those regions.
It's-
That's one way of doing it. The other way of doing it is a proteomic approach,
which is where
if you take RB and you co-precipitate it under drug-induced
conditions or not, do you see a different subset of E2Fs
being bound?
Yeah, that is actually a good idea. Thank you.
Last question.
Yeah. Great talk.
Thank you, Phil.
My question relates to just in patient samples, have you
seen
or analyzed those that have failed CDK4/6 inhibitor
therapy and looked at upregulation of these EPR target genes in
those samples?
Yeah, that's a great question, Phil.
We haven't. So doing the RB
chromatin mapping in tissue,
is something that, as I showed you, we can do.
We've done it in PDX tissue, and one of our big frontiers now is
to start doing this in human tumors.
So far, to be honest, our ability to do it in tissue requires fresh tissue.
So not even tissue that's been viably frozen. We need fresh tissue.
And so,
we've not been able to do it in the setting of clinical
samples, let alone with respect to response or resistance.
Yeah. Thanks.
All right. Thank you, Jonathan.
All right, so our last speaker is Nolan Prettykid from
the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
He works there with Todd Golub and others, and as I said, he's
also a breast medical oncologist, but doing some
outstanding genomics and computational research, in this case, looking at RNA
fusions and novel drivers.
Okay. All right. So firstly, thank you to the organizers and Dr.
Pru and Dr. Arteaga
for allowing me to present this work at ACR.
And I'm going to tell you about
our attempts to build a programmable nucleic acid sensing system
that might be useful for cancer.
And these are my disclosures.
And I'm going to start relatively simply, and I think it's safe to say that a major
goal of oncology is really to build medicines that eliminate cancer cells while
sparing healthy tissue. And most drugs, as we know, do this with
kind of a narrow therapeutic window, where they preferentially kill cancer cells
slightly more than healthy cells.
But really truly cancer-specific therapies and these magic bullet targets
like BCR-ABL in CML, HER2 positive breast
cancer,
they're actually quite rare when you look across solid tumors, yet are historically
the most impactful for patients. So the question is really how can we
increase this reservoir of truly cancer-specific targets?
And I think it's also safe to say that the most distinguishing feature of a cancer
cell is the genome itself. And you can see here a spectral
karyogram of chromosomes of a normal cell where each chromosome is painted a
different color, and it's clean.
And here is a breast cancer cell, where you can see the DNA has been amplified,
inverted, deleted, and rearranged into one another.
And everywhere that there are essentially two colors touching, and there can be
hundreds to thousands of these in an individual breast cancer, is
a barcode that exists only in cancer cells.
And the question of my postdoc, and also
increasingly my career, is how can we think about better exploiting these
cancer-specific breakpoints with recent advances in nucleic acid
targeting technologies?
And the target that we chose first are fusion genes or fusion RNAs, and as
we all know, it's when two genes are normally separated in space, they're fused
together at the DNA level, but they can also be expressed as RNA or
protein. And it's really changed the world for these patients when there is a
kinase involved because we can build small molecules to target them
selectively. At the same time, it's an uncomfortable fact that there are
many fusions that we have not cracked,
some examples being in sarcoma,
and this is unacceptable.
And at the same time in breast cancer, there are fusions that drive endocrine
therapy resistance in the advanced setting.
And we've shown that ER fusions can occur likely more frequently than previously
thought at a frequency of 9 to 10%.
And at the same time, there's private fusions, so N of one fusions that
might be more common in breast cancer than previously appreciated, and they often
can occur very early in cancer development, suggesting they may be truncal
targets or more homogeneous targets in a traditionally very heterogeneous disease.
So the first thing that we did is just quantify fusion RNAs in metastatic breast
cancer. So we used a cohort of 423 metastatic breast cancer
cases. Importantly, we used frozen tissue, which increases your sensitivity of
calling fusions by about sevenfold.
And the bottom line is that they're common in breast cancer, with basal and HER2
having the most unique fusions per cancer, with LumB and LumA
behind.
Greater than 90% of breast cancer cases do have a fusion RNA that we're able
to detect.And when you look across
cancers, common cancers, breast cancer again stands out among the
top, likely because
of a larger degree of genomic instability that's been confirmed with whole
genome sequencing studies.
And if you look at which ones are truly highly expressed, that might be
potential targets for a nucleic acid therapy, and you just define a simple
outlier threshold, 33% of metastatic breast cancers express at
least one fusion, sometimes multiple, relatively highly.
And these often involve driver-related genes such as ESR1 and
PI3K pathway members. But the majority of them, 98%, are
private. So whether or not they're drivers or passengers, we do not know.
But the point is that they're there and highly expressed.
These fusions that are highly expressed can also be preserved in a
patient that's had many lines of therapy.
So this is a Sankey plot that shows two truncal fusion RNAs that we
identified that was present in the breast primary, but at the time of a rapid
autopsy case, was preserved in every single metastatic tissue that was sampled
from this patient and absent from a matched normal tissue.
Again, suggesting that if we can think of a way to target these more thoughtfully,
it might be a way to cut through the heterogeneity in the advanced disease setting.
So a concept that we came up with is if we can use these nucleotides not as
direct biological targets, but almost like a molecular switch or trigger for a
modular therapeutic effect. So you can imagine you have a cancer-specific
barcode, develop some technology where it detects whether or not it's in
a cancer cell, and triggers something that would kill the cancer cell.
And conceptually, as I had mentioned, it needs to be patient scalable because
98% of these are patient-specific and
amenable, and we want it to be amenable to any cancer-specific nucleotide,
regardless of whether or not it's a passenger or a driver.
So there was a technology that caught our eye, and it's RNA editing,
and the premise is that you design a guide RNA that's complementary to a target in
the cell. This guide RNA has an intentional C to A mismatch,
and there's a protein that exists within cells, you don't have to introduce it like
CRISPR, called ADAR, that selectively deanimates that
mismatch on the adenosine into an inosine.
And it's been used to correct genetic mutations at
the RNA level, and there's some Phase 1 and Phase 2 studies being performed.
Our collaborators developed a twist on this technology where you make
the
mismatch not in the target, but in the guide.
And you make it so that it is in a trinucleotide context that is a
stop codon. So when it binds to its fusion RNA target,
the deamination happens on the guide, and it turns a stop
codon into an in-frame codon, essentially
ungating the translation of a downstream protein payload.
And we use this to sense things like to define cell states.
But we thought perhaps you can use this as a cancer-sensing protein
payload switch and express something downstream that is toxic.
And this technology was developed by Dr. Fei Chen and Dr.
Jeremy Koop at the Broad.
So we got to work and designed fusion-targeting RNA sensors, and we used two
broad architectures. Linear sensors, which essentially
hybridize directly across the fusion breakpoint.
And we also designed a new type of sensor called a gap sensor, where we
have one portion of the
guide RNA that binds to the five-prime partner and another portion that binds to
the three-prime partner. And the thought is that in three-dimensional space, you'll
still form that double-stranded RNA duplex that recruits ADAR and flips the
switch for the downstream protein payload.
So the first thing that we did is we tested this in the most contrived model, human
embryonic kidney cells, because they're easy to get a lot of DNA into.
And we targeted an ESR1 fusion, and we used a fluorescent reporter.
So we've transfected cells with an empty vector and those with the fusion, and this
is the fluorescence here. Blue do not have the fusion.
Red do have the fusion. These are different sensors on the
x-axis, and we found fairly selective protein expression using both
linear and gap sensor designs. And this is endpoint microscopy, showing
just the magnitude of effect that we see for selective protein
expression in this model.
Next, we needed to move to a more real-world model.
So we applied the same algorithm that we used to identify fusion RNAs in
patient tumors to human cell lines, and we found a highly
expressed ARFGAP2-Solf2 fusion in the MCF7 line.
We confirmed that this fusion exists using breakpoint spanning RT-PCR and defined a
real estate of about 1,000 base pairs surrounding the breakpoint to design sensors
against.
So this is the same experiment now moving to flow cytometry, targeting an
endogenously expressed fusion in MCF7 cells.
And we used the fusion negative line, MCF10A.
And this is the percent of mNeon expression in 10A, so a fusion negative line
versus the fusion positive line where we found selective protein expression
in cells that contain the fusion against an endogenous target.
So the next is we wanted to move beyond reporters to a more therapeutic
application, and we're interested in two broad therapeutic
payloads. You can imagine a rewiring payload that might be immune
stimulatory or a directly cytotoxic payload, and we decided to
start with a directly cytotoxic payload.
We decided to use a human-tested cytotoxic protein payload,
Icaspase9. And what this is, is a synthetic molecule that
has a dimerizing domain at the N-terminal region and
a caspase molecule in the C-terminal region.
You add a biologically inert AP1903 drug, it causes this to
dimerize and triggers apoptosis.
And this has been essentially used as a CAR T safety switch in pediatrics and
adults.
So we put our fusion targeting sensors, this time with
a cytotoxic payload in MCF7s. These are our controls on the right
where we have styrosporin, which is essentially our floor of
cancer cell killing. And we have a panel of NTCs here, and these
NTCs are non-targeting controls, and they are sensors
that target fusions not present in the cell line that we're targeting in
other contexts, and you can see the viability is around 100%.
And these are the fusion targeting sensors, and we were happy to see that both gap
and linear designs did cause a pretty profound decrease in cell viability in
MCF7s down to 80% at this one particular time
point.This is what the cells look like
when
transfected with the sensor. This is the NTC control, so it's targeting an ESR1
fusion that is not present in this line with the same cytotoxic
payload. And then this is the targeting sensor, so targeting the
RFGF2-SOX2 fusion that exists in this line, and you can see the cancer
cells undergo apoptosis. And then when you take the sensor
and you plug it into a cell line that does not have
the fusion,
there's minimal toxicity.
And then when you put the fusion into these cell lines,
we do see a modest effect, a decrease in viability, suggesting there is some
specificity here.
So, this is a clever trick that you can pull off in vitro, but there's
major challenges to overcome that we
are actively pursuing. One, we don't know the design rules of
why some sensors work better than others.
You could see the variability in the gap in linear sensors because we're testing
dozens at a time. So now, we're doing high throughput RNA
sensor screening in order to identify really the design rules for this
hybridization.
Delivery is always going to be an issue.
So we're collaborating with folks
in the viral nanoparticle antibody LNP field to see if we can deliver these
to a mouse in vivo. And then an interesting thing to think about is
what payload would you choose? We chose the most simple payload, which is a
directly cytotoxic payload, but you can imagine you can produce an immune
stimulatory payload,
drug baits, and even think of a synthetic payload that doesn't exist in the natural
world.
So from the design standpoint, we collaborated with
another physician scientist, Jordan Chenai, a master's student, and Shi
Wang from the Manguza Lab, also at the Broad.
And we designed a scalable and modular screen and vivo compatible
sensor backbone, where now we can essentially add any
sensor in any payload and test it in a high throughput way.
So, this is very preliminary results, but we're doing these small-scale fusion
RNA sensor library screens. We're able to express a fluorescent
payload, isolate cells that fusion positive and fusion
negative cells, that turn on the payload versus turn off the payload
and ask which are enriched. And our positive controls are fortunately going in
the right fractions, and negative controls are also going in the right fractions,
and we're able to test instead of dozens, thousands of sensors to really get these
design rules down.
So in summary, RNA sensors can leverage RNA editing to
selectively express protein payloads in cancer cells.
We have two sensor architectures, linear and gap sensors.
And the gap sensors are important because they really expand the design real
estate, and you could really enable targeting of any cancer
specific RNA. And importantly, whether or not it's a passenger or driver, because
remember, we're just using it as a molecular switch to turn something cytotoxic on.
RNA sensors armed with a pro-apoptotic payload can selectively kill cells harboring
the target RNA while sparing cells without it.
And more broadly, we feel this concept of nucleic acid sensing may offer a patient
scalable, modular, and precise strategy to selectively rewire protein-based
vulnerabilities in the cancer cells.
And our ongoing efforts are to define RNA design rules, expand payload classes,
target new fusions, and start our first in vivo experiments.
And another study that we presented at San Antonio, which I think is related to
this, is we did a
CT DNA genomic study where we looked at early metastatic breast
cancers with lethal or late-line metastatic breast cancers.
And the two time points were defined as patients who had a metastatic diagnosis
within six months, and the end point was six months within
death. And there's a median of five lines of therapy between these two time points
and a median interval of 819 days.
And this is what the early metastatic breast cancer look like, and it looks like
this is an OncoPrint, and you can see
mutation frequencies at which you would normally expect and has been published.
And then this is the lethal setting.
And you can see an absolute explosion of heterogeneity, which is not
surprising, but still sobering to have data supporting it,
just to see how heterogeneous these tumors are in the advanced setting.
Zooming in on a particular case, there's what I argue, really an
untenable heterogeneity that emerges in this setting.
This patient had seven ESR1 ligand-binding domain mutations, granted they were at
different frequencies, multiple amplifications, including on-target
amplifications of CDK4 and CDK6. And the
point and the reason why I think it's related a little bit to this work is I
think we need to think about, generally, more innovative methods to
target truncal events,
just because the amount of heterogeneity that develops in this late line
setting,
is what I would argue is untenable or preventing this from
happening in the first place.
So, with that said, I do think if you squint a little bit on the
horizon, there is maybe an era of
programmable cancer medicines coming, where we have advances in gene
editing, nucleic acid scalability.
We are able to produce billions of mRNA COVID vaccines and
spread them across the world. We can order a sensor and have it delivered
tomorrow that is patient specific.
There's been some awesome data supporting neoantigen personalized vaccine
at this conference. Artificial intelligence is going to help us better
design the nucleic acids that could be scalable to individual
patients. And there's already the FDA is thinking about platform specific
regulatory
things that need to happen. And they're mainly focusing on Mendelian genetic
disorders, but I think it would make sense to think about
how we can apply these platforms to cancer. So many challenges remain.
Some may be insurmountable, but I think the impact could be enormous.
So, firstly, thank you to my postdoc mentor, Todd Golub.
He built this environment where his group pursues bold
ideas that would be impactful if successful, and just amazing group, and he's an
amazing scientist to learn from. Alenez Lebron Torres is a
very motivated RA, who has helped a lot with this work.
Kate Santos is another RA who helps with the translational
work. And then my Dana-Farber mentor, Sarah, Nancy, and Hal,
whoHelp me
be a junior faculty clinically. And then
our collaborators, Fei Chen and Jeremy, who really opened up the technology to
apply it to cancer. I couldn't have had better collaborators on this project, and
we continue to collaborate. And also our other collaborators, Jordan and
Ensure. We have an awesome patient advocate, Susan, who was actually the first to
hear about this project. Adrian and Steffi, who
give us models to test this in. And I've been fortunate to receive some
funding on this high-risk project, which really has
enabled it. So thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to answer any questions.
All right. Any questions for Nolan?
Dr. Wall.
Really great talk. Really clever work.
Of course,
one can imagine the problem of
restricted delivery and effect.
Mm-hmm.
So it'd be really nice to design this in a way that
you could get
bystander effects as well.
Totally.
Have you thought about that?
Because I wonder if you can arrange this
delivery construct in a delivery strategy in a way
that you can actually do two genes simultaneously, one of which is
local and one of which has disseminated effects.
Yes. So you raise a couple of important points, and
we're thinking about that from multiple angles in
the design. So one angle is you can think about the payload itself.
We're thinking about secreted factors-
Right
... that would maybe
diffuse within the local environment and trigger some type of immuno effect.
I think that would be an interesting application.
Another component is the target itself.
There's no reason why we couldn't scale it up to multiple fusions,
and that first plot that I showed
gives you a sense that some of these breast cancers can have up to a dozen or
dozens of cancer-specific alterations, which is another way.
And then another way to think about it is just
the typical antibody LNP conjugates or nucleotide
conjugates. Maybe you can design the linker in a way so that it diffuses more
diffusely in the local tumor microenvironment.
Right.
So that's an excellent point.
The other thing is I thought it was really interesting that you said that these
fusions exist from early
point.
Mm-hmm.
Maybe not the initiating point, but early on, and they
persist.
Mm-hmm.
That does not say that they are essential for
the viability of the cell.
So
one of the things that I would worry about is resistance-
Mm-hmm
... generated by either mutation of the binding
site or the loss of that fusion RNA to begin with.
Do you know whether those fusion products are actually
essential for viability?
Yeah, so we have a direction that we're thinking about.
It's a little too early to talk about now, but we're using a
high-scale
functional genomics to define whether or not these are truly passengers or
drivers.
But excellent question.
Yeah, I wonder if you could comment or speculate more on different payloads.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so we thought a lot about different payloads, and we tested a
couple. One we're curious about are these drug
bait payloads where you can turn them off quickly in case there is toxicities, like
HSV-TK is one that requires a prodrug in order for
the protein to kill the cell. We think that would be interesting, and it's one of
the things that we liked about the ICAS SP9 mechanism.
So if you have background, you can just take away
the prodrug that triggers the cytotoxicity.
Other payloads that we think about are cell surface markers for ADCs.
Like, can you turn a triple-negative breast cancer into a dead kinase HER2
expressing, which I think would be an interesting application.
And then obviously the immune component is
probably the most exciting in our eyes because, in
reality, there is no way,
at least that exists in 2026, that you can deliver something like this to every
cell. So can you reprogram the immune system in some way so that if you hit
10% of the cells, you can still get something that is clinically meaningful?
Yeah.
Any other questions?
If not, we'll thank Nolan for an outstanding
presentation.
And
I'd like to again thank the speakers for
their presentations. This was great.
And then I'll wish you all a good rest of your AACR
meeting and encourage you to come to San Antonio
Breast Cancer Symposium,
and
submit abstracts and hopefully make presentations there.
So thank you for your time